it's only my life and I'm fighting for
people who don't follow the guidelines
are playing Russian roulette with the
gift of life it's really a ridiculous
answer to a man's life
I have nothing to heart
my name is Norman D Smith I'm 63 years
old and I have inoperable liver cancer
the only way that I could stay alive is
to have a liver transplant
Smith seemed to be making progress in
his cancer recovery he was being treated
by some of the best doctors in the world
at Cedars Sinai Hospital in Los Angeles
he was on a transplant list and he had
completed a successful clinical trial
that had his doctors dubbing him a
miracle man then his cancer returned and
two months before he would have received
a transplant he got this dear mr. Smith
this letter is to inform you that your
name has been removed from the National
wait list with the United Network for
Organ Sharing you have been removed due
to non-compliance of our substance abuse
contract in the midst of his treatment
Smith's oncologist at Cedars Sinai
prescribed medical marijuana to
alleviate pain brought on by back
surgery and chemotherapy Cedars sinus
transplant program who ever considered
that doctor prescribed medicine to be
something different substance abuse I'm
not a substance abuser
I'm a taxpaying active citizen of
America I was an extreme pain extreme
discomfort and was put on huge amounts
and various pain medications to deal
with I got off I didn't want to be on
the pain medication and for pain relief
as first group of medical marijuana
obtained it and went on a medical
marijuana regimen marijuana is
considered substance abuse the hospital
did not want to speak on camera but
referred us to Peggy Stewart a clinical
social worker with UCLA's transplant
program there are other ways to treat
your pain and
the rules are such then you should be
able to adhere to that policy now Smith
must attend Alcoholics Anonymous classes
and abstain for marijuana use just to
get back on the list but time has
already run out and even he knows that
my chances of getting a liver transplant
in time is a longshot people who don't
follow the guidelines are playing
Russian roulette with the gift of life
cedars-sinai said in an email that their
reasoning lied in a deadly combination
between a mold found in marijuana called
Aspergillus and medication taken before
and after a transplant
Aspergillus fungus can lead to infection
in immunosuppressed patients which the
liver transplant population is comprised
of immunosuppressive patients take
medication that prevents the rejection
of transplanted organs this complication
is why transplant programs at UCLA at
cedars-sinai and across the United
States don't see a difference between
medical marijuana and marijuana as
substance abuse the modality of it
really is not a issue I feel it's
frustrated angry
I believe morally ethically medically
scientifically they're wrong
unfortunately the story of Norman Smith
is not an uncommon one to us Americans
for safe access
Stephanie Sher works to improve medical
and legal barriers to medical cannabis
the truth is is that Norman lives in Los
Angeles and there are laboratories that
he can take his medicine to and make
sure that it doesn't have contaminants
actually Smith did need to take his
medicine anywhere the dispensary he used
near his house had its marijuana tested
for Aspergillus and other fungi at SC
laboratories a facility that tests
marijuana in full compliance with FDA
and EPA agricultural guidelines it's
safer than the spinach and lettuce
leaves
additionally the lab abides by the
United Nations Office on Drugs and Crime
manual it's really a ridiculous answer
to to a man's life
despite technology like this transplant
programs are not convinced because of
the possibility that their data could be
wrong I would still have some
reservations about this I would have to
have some convinced
thing data we presented Stewart with
some more data a 2009 study from the
American Journal on transplantation that
looked at marijuana use among potential
liver candidates the result was that the
survival of marijuana users was not
significantly different for marijuana
non-users
we're not really looking at it from that
perspective that the outcomes are the
same if you potentially expose the new
organ to any risk factor that's a
problem sure since the real problem is
patients left in limbo
Norman is now in a very large community
of our patients that can't find a place
in the system she says that's because
the world is still changing the reality
is is that we live in a society that is
just starting to open its mind to seeing
cannabis used as a medicine cedars-sinai
spokesperson said in an email that we do
not make a moral or ethical judgment
about marijuana use our concern is for
the health and safety of our patients as
an advocate I'm really tired of people
telling me that this isn't about
morality pull behind the curtain and
there isn't anything there except for
their opinions about the morality of
using this medicine they're looking out
for themselves as far as the looking out
for me
I'm disillusioned by that I disagree
that the selection committee makes moral
judgments we do not discriminate against
patients who have had a criminal history
who have done illicit acts so similarily
we're not discriminating against medical
marijuana users you see what's happening
to Smith represents something bigger one
of the first battles being fought over
the place of medical marijuana in
medicine and this battle isn't just
unique to Smith it's a fight for many
patients caught in between managing
their pain and receiving a transplant
since I've started Americans for safe
access we in our database at our office
we know of over two dozen patients
are going through this and unfortunately
half of them have passed away because
they were not able to get these
transplants now I just accept it I deal
with it and they take one day at a time
I move forward I try to get a quality of
life every day and I realized that the
chances of Cedars changing their mind
it's a long shot but if I can affect the
change so be it it's probably too late
for me but I hope it makes it easier for
the next guy and there's plenty of us
out there